Bob Woodward drew from hundreds of hours
of interviews for his new book fear
Trump in the White House he says fear
includes details from participants and
witnesses to the Trump administration
the president is strongly criticizing
the book this Woodward book is a total
it's a total fraud the book means
nothing it's a work of fiction I'm very
happy with the way it turned out because
I think the book has been totally
discredited in our interview with FBI
director Christopher ray yesterday we
asked what he thinks of Woodward's
claims of chaos and discord in the
administration you live in Washington so
you also know that much of this town is
also talking about Bob Woodward's book
called fear and in that book he
describes an administration which you
are part of but he's specifically
describing the White House as having a
nervous breakdown of executive power
have you experienced any of that I have
not seen a nervous breakdown of
executive power I have also not read mr.
Woodward's book and I'm not sure whether
I'll ever find time fear is published by
Simon & Schuster a division of CBS Bob
Woodward is with us now here in studio
57 good morning thank you I'm gonna ask
you about FBI director Ray's comments
about your book in just a second but I
know you this book is with Simon &
Schuster it's a division of CBS and
you've had a number of your books
featured on 60 minutes what do you make
of what's happening here yes that's a
great question and you CBS has gone
through a scandal let's call it what it
is I know CBS very well they own Simon &
Schuster my publisher done 19 books the
Nixon storm the Iraq war the Afghan war
now the Trump storm and they are well
led independent great leadership Carolyn
Reedy
John Karp my editor Alice Mayhew I've
worked with her for 47 years on all of
those books a tough thoughtful editor 60
minutes did all of these books I
remember going back to Watergate and
there was a young reporter named Lesley
Stahl we
working on this story there is a great
producer for 60 minutes named Bob
Anderson who would come down and review
the basis of the books I've wrote about
the Iraq war about the Afghan war
where'd this come from let's listen to
the tapes I trusted him are you trying
to say Bob will be okay at CBS exactly
right because you've got strength people
go through tough times
I just from intimate involvement with
the books with 60 minutes with Scott
Pelley would come and interview me and
do this kind of excavation of the
experience I had so you are going to be
fine if you stick with your values there
is a great story in the New York Times
by Jim Stewart about how the decision
was made by the CBS Board and it shows
exactly that there were there was a
cover-up
there were lies and then they finally
faced the reality of what was going on
with your form I actually agree with you
and I really appreciate you saying this
it's tough to see your company's name
with the word in front of it besiege
that's very difficult but I there are a
lot of talented hard-working people here
I say heads up and onward but it is
difficult it is a scandal we're going
through it but as you said our values
and our core is very very strong and I
think at the time talking about your
book okay but you two women what's your
feeling about this
not John but you too because this is
about the treatment of women in a way
that is truly outrageous and I think the
society is not going to stand for this
anymore and this is and again look at
how this was exposed The New Yorker
magazine the Los Angeles Times and
confidential source
people who were willing to be trusted
and so there's a connection to all
that's going on agree yeah and just to
answer your question Gail and I feel
like we have spoken publicly about it
perhaps far too many times we talked
about it 10 months ago and we repeat it
were talking about we're still talking
about it and you're talking about that
being said we're journalists and we hold
other people accountable and then it's
the heart of journalism that's what
James Madison talked about that's the
First Amendment about holding government
officials and those public figures
accountable in his words and so we are
accountable as well in our own shop and
it also has to do with who writes
history people were in charge who helped
write history which is what your books
are about which is how history is told
you don't get history from just the
public statements that are made at a
podium you get them by real reporting
and asking people and that's really the
craft that you do but let me ask you
because the public does in this era when
the media is under fire for our
integrity in many different sorts of
ways when someone like the FBI director
who is a man of incredible integrity as
you can tell says that's not the
executive that I encounter one that's
that's having a nervous breakdown
how do you reconcile those well his
experience is limited with Trump I spent
over a year on this I have literally
hundreds of hours of tapes with people
who were there if you've looked at the
book they're very specific incident very
detailed and it is a kind of it opens
the window look going back to the Nixon
case going any of these books you're
gonna have what I call this survival
denial by somebody who wants to be
politically connected with the president
and that's fine
but is the great editor at The
Washington Post Ben Bradley said the
truth emerges and it does and I've done
this time and time again where you get
denials oh Nixon and Kissinger did not
pray on the eve of Nixon's resignation
well you are getting denials Bob and yes
but you also have tapes would you ever
release any of them
if somebody comes out and denies
something specifically and says it
doesn't accurately portray my experience
at the White House that's what's called
the non I mean is he going to say that
that document that's reproduced in the
book would you release tapes well if if
somebody really wants to challenge me of
course of course but I again I've made
agreements with people that these
sources are going to remain confidential
Bob you've covered a lot of
administration's when you were doing the
reporting for this what didn't you hear
one of the things you're used to hearing
from every administration that just was
absent in this administration well it's
not a team yeah time and time again the
president is the one who is alone on how
to deal with some of these national
security issues the whole cabinet meets
with him in the Pentagon there was a
long description of it and James Madison
Terry of Defense says that the great
gift of the greatest generation is this
rules-based international order and the
Secretary of State says this has kept
the peace for 70 years Trump does not
want to hear about it and he gets mad
and said all of this is BS and at the
end you literally have the Secretary of
Defense because this was a meeting in
the tank which is the meeting place of
the Joint Chiefs they wanted to get
Trump away from the TV and so forth it
is deflated and this is when Secretary
of State Tillerson as has been reported
says the the president is effing [ __ ]
yeah you sort of in the book that way -
thank you thank you that thank you very
much thank you very much thank you good
luck you're gonna be fine thank you a
lot of information in that book it's
called fear Trump in the White House
it's on sale wherever you like to buy
your books